so if we can step back into another
beautiful world which is the actual
mechanics the dirty mess of it of the
human brain is is there something for
people who might not know is there
something in common or describe the key
parts of the brain that are important
for intelligence or just in general one
of the different parts of the brain that
you're curious about that you've studied
and that are just good to know about
when you're thinking about cognition
well my area of expertise if I have one
is prefrontal cortex so what's that
or do we it depends on who you ask the
the the the the technical definition is
has is anatomical it there are there are
parts of your brain that are responsible
for motor behavior and they're very easy
to identify and the region of your
cerebral cortex they out needs sort of
outer crust of your brain that lies in
front of those is defined as the
prefrontal cortex and we say anatomical
sorry to interrupt so that's referring
to sort of the geographic region yeah as
opposed to some kind of functional
definition exactly so that it this is
kind of the coward's way out and I'm
telling you what the prefrontal cortex
is just in terms of like what part of
the real estate it occupies the thing in
the front of them yeah exactly and and
in fact the early history of you know
the neuro scientific investigation of
what this like front part of the brain
does is sort of funny to read because
you know it was really it was really
World War one that started people down
this road of trying to figure out what
different parts of the brain the human
brain do in the sense that there were a
lot of people with brain damage who came
back from the war with brain damage and
it that provided as tragic as that was
it provided
an opportunity for scientists to try to
identify the functions of different
brain regions and it wasn't actually
incredibly productive but one of the
frustrations that neuropsychologist
faced was they couldn't really identify
exactly what the deficit was that arose
from damage to this these most you know
kind of frontal parts of the brain it
was just a very difficult thing to you
know to you know to pin down there were
a couple of neuropsychologists who
identified through through a large
amount of clinical experience in close
observation they started to put their
finger on a syndrome that was associated
with frontal damage actually one of them
was a Russian neuropsychologist named
Gloria who you know students of
cognitive psychology still read and and
what he started to figure out was that
the frontal cortex was somehow involved
in flexibility the in in in guiding
behaviors that required someone to
override a habit or to do something
unusual or to change what they were
doing in a very flexible way from one
moment to another so focused on like new
experiences and so so the way your brain
processes and acts in new experiences
yeah what later helped bring this
function into better focus was a
distinction between controlled and
automatic behavior or - in in other
literature's this is referred to as
habitual behavior versus goal directed
behavior so it's very very clear that
the human brain has pathways that are
dedicated to habits - things that you do
all the time and they need to be autumn
at they don't require you to concentrate
too much so that leaves your cognitive
capacity free to do other things just
think about the difference between
driving when you're learning to drive
versus driving after you're fairly
expert there are brain pathways that
slowly absorb those frequently performed
behaviors so that they can be habits so
that they can be automatic so that
that's kind of like the purest form of
learning
I guess it's happening there which is
why I mean this is kind of jumping ahead
which is why that perhaps is the most
useful for us to focusing on and trying
to see how artificial intelligent
systems can learn is that the way it's
interesting III do think about this
distinction between controlled and
automatic or goal directed and habitual
behavior a lot in thinking about where
we are in AI research but but just to
finish to finish the the kind of
dissertation here the the the role of
the front of the prefrontal cortex is
generally understood these days sort of
in in Contra distinction to that
habitual domain in other words the
prefrontal cortex is what helps you
override those habits it's what allows
you to say well what I usually do in
this situation is acts but given the
context I probably should do why I mean
the elbow bump is a great example right
if you know reaching out and shaking
hands is a probably habitual behavior
and it's the prefrontal cortex that
allows us to bear in mind that there's
something unusual going on right now and
in this situation I need to not do the
usual thing the kind of behaviors that
Luria reported and he built tests for
you know detecting these kinds of things
we're exactly like this so in other
words when I stick out my hand I want
you instead to present your elbow a
patient with frontal damage would have
great deal of trouble with that you know
somebody preferring their hand would
elicit you know a handshake the
prefrontal cortex is what allows us to
say oh no hold on that's the usual thing
but I'm I have the ability to bear in
mind even very unusual contexts and to
reason about what behavior is
appropriate there just to get a sense is
are us humans special in the presence of
the prefrontal cortex do mice have a
prefrontal cortex do other mammals that
we can study if you if no then how do
they integrate new experiences yeah
that's a that's a really tricky question
and a very timely question because we
have revolutionary new technologies for
monitoring measuring and also causally
influencing neural behavior in mice and
fruit flies and these techniques are not
fully available even for studying brain
function in in monkeys let alone humans
and so it's a it's a very sort of for me
at least a very urgent question whether
the kinds of things that we want to
understand about human intelligence can
be pursued in these other organisms and
you know to put it briefly there's
disagreement you know people who study
fruit flies will often tell you hey
flies are smarter than you think and
they'll point to experiments where fruit
flies were able to learn new behaviors
we're able to generalize from one
stimulus to another in a way that
suggests that they have abstractions
that guide their generalization I've had
many conversations in which I will start
by observing you know recounting some
some observation about Mouse behavior
where it seemed like mice were taking an
awfully long time to learn a task that
for a human would be profoundly trivial
and I will conclude from that that mice
really don't have the cognitive
flexibility that we want to explain and
that a mouse researcher will say to me
well you know hold on that experiment
may not have worked because you asked a
mouse to
deal with stimuli and behaviors that
were very unnatural for the mouse if
instead you kept the logic of the
experiment the same but put you know and
put it in a you know presented it the
information in a way that aligns with
what mice are used to dealing with in
their natural habitats you might find
that a mouse actually has more
intelligence than you think and then
they'll go on to show you videos of mice
doing things in their natural habitat
which seem strikingly intelligent you
know dealing with you know physical
problems you know I have to drag this
piece of food back to my you know back
to my lair but there's something in my
way and how do I get rid of that thing
so I think I think these are open
questions to put it you know to sum that
up and then taking a small step back so
related to that is you kind of mentioned
we're taking a little shortcut by saying
it's a geographic geographic part of the
the prefrontal cortex is a region of the
brain but if we what's your sense in a
bigger philosophical view prefrontal
cortex and the brain in general do you
have a sense that it's a set of
subsystems in the way we've kind of
implied that are they're pretty distinct
or - or degrees of that or to what
degree is it a giant interconnected mess
where everything kind of does everything
and is impossible to disentangle them
I think there's overwhelming evidence
that there's functional differentiation
that it's clearly not the case that all
parts of the brain are doing the same
thing this follows immediately from the
kinds of studies of brain damage that we
were chatting about before it's obvious
from what you see if you stick an
electrode in the brain and measure
what's going on at the level of you
neural activity having said that there
are two other things to add which kind
of I don't know maybe tug in the other
direction
one is that it's when you look carefully
at functional differentiation in the
brain
what you usually end up concluding at
least this is my observation of the
literature is that the the differences
between regions are graded rather than
being discrete so it doesn't seem like
it's easy to divide the brain up into
true modules where you know that are you
know that have clear boundaries and that
have you know like like clear channels
of communication between them instead
lies to the prefrontal cortex yeah oh
yeah yeah the prefrontal cortex is made
up of a bunch of different sub regions
the you know the functions of which are
not clearly defined and which you know
the borders of which seem to be quite
vague and then then there's another
thing that's popping up in very recent
research which you know which involves
application of these new techniques
which there are a number of studies that
suggest that parts of the brain that we
would have previously thought were quite
focused in their function are actually
carrying signals that we wouldn't have
thought would be there for example
looking in the primary visual cortex
which is classically thought of as
basically the first cortical way station
for processing visual information
basically what it should care about is
you know where are the edges in this
scene that I'm viewing it turns out that
if you have enough data you can recover
information from primary visual cortex
about all sorts of things like you know
what what behavior the animal is engaged
in right now and what what how much
reward is on offer in the task that it's
pursuing so it's clear that even even
regions whose function is pretty well
defined at a course brain are
nonetheless carrying some information
about information from very different
domains so you know the history of
neuroscience is sort of this oscillation
between the two views that you
articulated you know the kind of modular
view
then the big you know mush view and you
know I think I guess we're gonna end up
somewhere in the middle
which is which is unfortunate for our
understanding because the mod there's
something about our you know conceptual
system that finds it's easy to think
about a modular eye system and easy to
think about a completely
undifferentiated system but something
that kind of lies in between is
confusing but we're gonna have to get
used to it I think
you